this morning we were talking about this
country's Child Care crisis and that is
definitely the word for it millions of
American families spend more than a
quarter of their income on child care
and that's if they can find it because
since the pandemic began many facilities
have closed others are struggling to
rehire their workers and our Meg Oliver
talked to parents in the middle of all
this may Good morning Tony good morning
to you we went to Massachusetts and
Wisconsin and met with parents battling
skyrocketing costs and limited access to
child care forcing them to make tough
decisions
Amelia Emanuel is like so many single
mothers I start my day between 4 30 and
5. other foot I am a single parent I
kind of explained to her like we have to
share the responsibilities in the
morning you got the other side it gets
really difficult just because I can move
fast she can't move fast the 33 year old
working mom and college student commutes
an hour every morning so her
four-year-old daughter Eliana can go to
this daycare on the south side of Boston
if you don't have child care then you
now have to stay home if you have to
stay home then you can't work if you
can't work you have no income
Massachusetts leads the country with the
most expensive child care for an average
family with an infant it's pricier than
some colleges at more than twenty
thousand a year Emmanuel applied for a
low-income voucher through the state
instead of paying 250 a week for daycare
she now pays
11.35 as soon as I got the voucher I
knew exactly what locations I wanted my
daughter to be in not every location in
the better neighborhoods will accept
your voucher across the United States
more than 50 percent of Americans live
in a child care desert meaning there's
either no child care or there's more
children than licensed care slots Utah
Nevada New York and West Virginia are
among the worst it's a nationwide crisis
pushing some parents to the brink when
this daycare is shut down what went
through your minds what are we going to
do who's going to take care of our kids
so I actually did lose my job sorry
emotional that's okay so yeah an
important impact on my performance too
much last year could you keep up what
you were doing taking care of your kids
and working it
population close to 200 000 more than
1200 children are on a waitlist for
child care last November when this
daycare shut down with little notice
full-time working moms Virginia moss and
Tiffany Simon took action we had dinner
together two nights in a row and we're
just running numbers and figuring out
what's going to make sense and we felt
like we could do it hi they bought the
building and within two months opened
joyful Beginnings Academy hiring
management 20 daycare workers and
enrolling 75 kids
it's a small fix in a desperate area
their school already has a wait list of
nearly 100 Kids we've seen both sides
we've felt the pain both sides and so
now we can go and educate that this is a
problem and we need to do something
about it if Virginia and Tiffany didn't
step in and reopen this daycare facility
where would you all be I probably would
have had to turn around sell me home
move in with my family really yeah and
one of us would have probably left our
jobs what is this child care facility
mean to your community
I think it's bonded our community
together
um especially living in a neighborhood
with a lot of little kids we all kind of
went through the struggle together
the daycare opened it was Advocates are
lobbying Congress to pass the child care
for Working Families act so families
wouldn't have to pay more than seven
percent of their income on child care
but affordability is just one part of
this huge problem then there's the
access so without continued investment
and better pay for daycare workers you
can't open up more facilities such a
true Virginia and Tiffany I love the
woman in the beginning who summed up
what happens if you don't have the job
if you don't have the child care it all
comes the Vicious Circle yeah you don't
have you can't work it's such a vicious
cycle yeah and this problem can be fixed
yeah I mean the the the the piece of
legislation sounds great on the surface
people will have questions I think about
what it does to to tax bills but we all
have an interest in people being able to
have kids and families and jobs right
and the solution is not oh you take care
of your kids you stay home that's not
how our economy works anymore you know
two income households are the norm uh
and so we all have a stake in this and
even if those daycare facilities are
provided they're still expensive and so
you're dealing with Rising costs across
all you know food costs more gas costs
more and child care is just another dent
in everyone's wallet gotta solve it it'd
make the economy hum along a lot better
if we did so Meg thank you very much